i love you an act of true love without a
frozen
heart making a satisfying finale can be
tough and these disney flicks almost
ended
a bit differently disney is known for
giving audiences happy endings where
everything is tied with a neat little
bow
these flicks from the mouse house
originally had
much different third acts than what we
got in the final product
from giant sea monster battles and the
end of magic
to leaving the jungle let's see which
disney movies
originally had darker endings you
wouldn't
kill your old uncle i'm
like you the ending of pixar's sea
monster fable luca won over the hearts
of audiences around the world
and even made them weepy what's
interesting is that the film
almost took a different route in its
third act and would have played up the
humans vs sea monster feud that looms
over the film
initially the climax would have centered
around alberto transforming into a giant
kraken with luca
ultimately having to stand up against
the humans for his misunderstood friend
the luca team eventually decided to
lower the stakes and give the film a
more simple resolution which
certainly worked in the film's favor
they are
the winners in the conclusion of rheya
and the last dragon
after being shot by namari sisu comes
back to life
alongside all the other dragons
surprisingly the filmmakers initially
debated whether or not sisu and the
other dragons should return
or if a resurrected sisu should remain
the last dragon
in order to stay true to the east asian
themes the creative team decided to
stick with a happier ending
and one that promoted prosperity
hope you don't mind she brought some
friends
[Music]
while pixar's soul ends with joe getting
another chance to live his life on earth
and make his lifelong dreams come to
fruition
that wasn't always the case the folks at
pixar initially debated about whether or
not the film
should end with joe passing on to the
great beyond instead of getting another
chance on earth multiple endings were
thrown around
but the crew soon figured out how they
could have joe return to earth without
betraying the themes of the story or the
audience
so we all decided to give you another
chance
onward is the rare pixar film that is
notably absent
of a clear villain but in the initial
stages of the film that wasn't the case
story supervisor kelsey mann revealed
that in the earlier stages of the film
there was a true villain who was
guarding the hidden gem needed to bring
back
ian and barley's late father the film's
crew
ended up scrapping the character as they
couldn't figure out a real motive or
purpose for a villainous character
wow that's really terrible
i know part of frozen's popularity can
be credited to how the film handles the
themes of sisterhood between
anna and elsa the film may not have been
successful if the team
at disney decided to go with their
original plans
producer peter del veccho revealed that
anna and elsa weren't always supposed to
be sisters
as elsa was initially planned to be the
villain of the film
in an attempt to make the film more
similar to its source material
han's christian andersons the snow queen
in another twist
the film would have ended in a giant ice
battle with anna and elsa
right in the center of it no i'm not
leaving without you elsa
yes you are if tangled had stayed closer
to the original source material
the film would have featured mother
gothel tricking flynn into believing
that rapunzel was
no more in retaliation flynn would have
thrown himself from the tower
only to be saved by a bush that caused
him to lose his eyesight
instead the filmmakers went a different
route giving the characters a much
happier ending with rapunzel reuniting
with her parents and
marrying flynn the film almost ended
differently
until the release of a certain
documentary made the creative team
reconsider the film originally had the
characters of destiny
bailly and hank being left behind at the
marine park
after watching the sea world expose
documentary
blackfish the film's crew reconsidered
and decided that the characters needed
an
ending where they were happier and truly
free
well i guess we'll go back home and
brush up on the anemone
the little mermaid's climax almost took
a darker turn
and originally featured a sequence where
ursula kidnaps eric and attempts to
drown him
underneath the waves the film's crew
thought twice about the scene and deemed
it too violent which led them to change
it to eric defeating ursula and rescuing
ariel while sailing a wrecked ship
everyone knows the ending of tarzan
where jane and her father decide to
abandon civilization
and stay in the jungle with tarzan but
the film's ending
almost went in the exact opposite
direction that would have been
more similar to its source material
featuring tarzan leaving his ape family
behind and heading to human civilization
to live with jane
directors chris buck and kevin lima
ultimately decided against this
as they didn't want to have the titular
hero abandon his family
sarabi and i didn't see you at the
presentation of simba
that was today the lion king is already
one of disney's darker animated films
but it almost had a much darker finale
the film's final showdown between simba
and scar had initially gone down
differently as storyboards revealed that
scar successfully threw his nephew
off pride rock before ultimately falling
off himself
and succumbing to the flames simba is
ultimately shown to be alive as a tree
had broken
his fall the disney execs likely saw
this ending as too intense for children
and had the animation team change it
to scar being eaten alive by the hyenas
this admittedly is still pretty dark
i've got to take you back to the man
village
the man village disney's animated jungle
book ends with mowgli falling for a girl
and following her back to the man
village
but originally the film didn't end there
in fact
earlier versions of the film followed
mowgli reuniting with his mother
as well as a time jump revealing that he
is now at odds with the animals that
raised him
if that wasn't enough the film would
have ended with mowgli returning to the
jungle to hunt down the villainous sheer
khan with a rifle
spooky i need crews never mind that now
no and you're back here
now get her back cars 3 ends with
aspiring racer cruz ramirez taking
lightning mcqueen's spot in the
penultimate race the film
almost featured an ending where cruz
didn't get her chance to show off her
racing skills
and instead had lightning winning the
race and the film would have ended with
the start of a mentorship
is it safe i guess i'll find out
the incinerator scene in toy story 3 is
one of the most
emotionally intense sequences in any
disney movie
director lee unkrich revealed that he
and the team behind the film had
actually made an alternate cut
where it ends right when woody buzz and
the gang are about to meet their
untimely end in the incinerator
cutting out the moment where they are
saved by the aliens
this cut of the film was obviously never
meant to be released
and was only made as a practical joke
thank
goodness we're just here for him
the climactic chase in lilo and stitch
almost went down
differently initially featuring stitch
hijacking a commercial airplane and
flying through the city in order to
rescue lilo
crashing into several buildings in the
process due to tragic events that
occurred during the time of the film's
production
the animators came to the decision to
reanimate the scene so it wouldn't
resemble the recent tragedy
with the plane being changed to a
starship and the buildings into
mountains
toy story 4 certainly concluded on an
emotional note
albeit it was one that felt appropriate
director josh cooley revealed that the
initial ending was going to go a
different route with woody and bo peep
parting ways woody would go back to be
with bonnie
while beau peep gives up her status as a
lost toy and goes to live with harmony
in the end cooley found that this ending
would go against the film's message of
accepting change
and instead had woody join beau as a
lost toy
to infinity and beyond
these disney films certainly would have
felt like much different movies if they
decided to go on a darker or
more melancholy route from near fatal
experiences
heroes becoming villains and even the
underdogs never getting a chance to
succeed
it's clear that the creative minds at
disney made the right choice
is there a disney movie that you feel
should have ended differently